Before I begin,
I wanted to,
um,
say something about our speaker on Wednesday.
Uh,
Andrew Red Leaf.
first of all,
uh,
he had accepted our invitation to go to lunch with some of you.
So,
um,
I want to arrange an event,
uh,
actually at one of the colleges,
a cafeteria and I haven't figured out,
maybe one of you has a suggestion.
Uh,
especially if we can get a,
see what college he was here that we did it in his college cause he graduated
from Iu.
Um,
I forgotten which one that was.
It had a nice room upstairs.
Uh,
so maybe I'll try to get that one again cause he said he doesn't particularly
care.
Maybe I should take them to another one
maybe.
Yeah,
if you can suggest the college,
uh,
which has a nice room for,
and then it will be both.
I'll come and readily full come.
Uh,
and uh,
uh,
so that's,
that's this Wednesday.
And uh,
so what I'm going to do is email you the details.
If you could email me if you're interested in coming and so we can have a good
size group and a discussion.
Okay.
Uh,
so I just wanted to say a little bit about red leaf.
he,
uh,
founded white box advisers,
in 2000,
so that's eight years ago,
uh,
and is now up to 1.8 billion assets under management.
So,
uh,
assets under management is how much money he's drawn in from investors.
So he's doing quite well.
Uh,
and,
uh,
he has some celebrity status among hedge fund managers.
Uh,
normally I put on the website,
um,
for that verb March 5th,
under our class syllabus,
a New York Times article about him entitled curiosity has its merits.
Uh,
I guess it struck the author of that article that,
uh,
red leaf is just a very guy who was very curious about a lot of things.
He wants to know how things work and why things are happening.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that might be a natural impulse and some people have that more than others.
It's probably a good impulse to have if you're going into investment,
but of course he turns it into a productive purpose.
Uh,
and so there were a couple of examples from that article.
One is that,
uh,
there's a literature in finance about options and stock price performance,
which goes back 10 years.
That shows that something is not quite right with the way companies issue
options.
Uh,
so let me,
let me remind you what happens.
What's happening increasingly is that employees are top executive employees,
at least in companies,
are rewarded as part of their compensation with options on the value of the
stock of the company they work for.
So you work for Xyz Corporation,
the share is trading at $10 a share.
They would give you at the money or out of the money options,
say options to buy the stock at $11 a share.
All right?
That's $1 more than it costs now in the market.
So those options are worthless unless the price of the stock goes up.
And so that's supposed to incentivize you as a manager to get the stock price
up,
uh,
and then you make money if the price of the stock rises above,
in that case $11 a share.
So that all that is fine.
It sounds good that managers should be given options because it will incentivize
them to work for the benefit of the corporation.
The problem is that's been revealed in finance literature is that,
uh,
there's an uncanny tendency for the stock price to go up after the company
awards,
large quantities of options to its executives.
That sounds suspicious.
I mean,
you could say,
well that means the options are really working well because it really motivated
the managers and they did something and made the company worth more.
But if it suddenly goes up right after their issue,
you kind of suspect that something is something is screwy here.
And so there's,
there's been a number of articles that documented that stock prices tend to jump
shortly after options,
our issue to managers.
And so,
um,
the immediate suspicion that this raise and think it's more than a suspicion is
that companies will time announcement of good news until after they issue the
options right there.
The managers of the companies that are kind of a group helping each other,
right?
Let's,
let's award options to each other.
Uh,
and then after we award them,
we'll announce the good news and the stock price will go up and you guys will
get money.
Okay.
There's a tax incentive to do that.
If they awarded a options that were in the money,
that means already exercisable at profit,
uh,
then they would be subject to a tax liability immediately.
Uh,
so they don't want to do that.
So they want to issue them out of the money and then announced the news that
brings them into money.
Uh,
and so that's been proven that companies do that.
More recently,
there was a,
and I was just reading about this in the,
in the times there was an article,
um,
by,
uh,
Eric Lee that,
showed that it's not just announcement of news that does it.
It's also that companies must be backdating options because Alicia,
that some of the price jumps that occur after the options are issued couldn't
possibly have been manipulated by the company's news announcements.
It must've been that they somehow knew on the issuance date that the stock price
was going to go up,
but he said they couldn't possibly know that,
uh,
in these general circumstances.
So Lee concluded that companies were fraudulent Lee backdating options.
He concluded this on the basis of a statistical test.
You see what I'm saying?
If stock price option,
if stock options tend to be issued as announced by the company later,
uh,
on just before stock prices go up,
there's no way that that can be right because nobody can know exactly when the
stock price is going to go up.
So they must have been lying about the date that they issued the options.
Okay.
So that you understand that issue about backdating it was,
this article by Eric Lee was uh,
uh,
something of a scandal and it led them to regulatory authorities,
to,
uh,
his name is Eric Lee regulatory authorities.
Then realize that some things,
there's some fraud going on.
Not most corporations,
I think Leah identified a small number,
but definitely some of them that were lying about the day,
you know what I'm saying?
They would announce a in December that we issued back in August these options to
our executives.
Funny thing,
the uh,
uh,
stock price sword right between August and December when they announced it.
So the regulatory authorities are start,
we're starting to look into this.
That's fraud to backdate options.
So what does Andrew Red Leaf does?
He decided to do his own study parallel to Eric leaves and much more pervasive.
So he was going after himself,
finding out all the companies that we're backdating options,
trying to beat the SEC and the regulatory authorities to the conclusion.
And then what'd he do?
He shorted the stocks or whatever the benefit.
Once they're investigated their stock prices and their bond prices are going to
fall.
So he,
he did the,
he found out who they were using similar methods to Lee's and uh,
and profited from it.
Is that a good thing?
Well,
that's the way Wall Street works,
or at least a 10.
Some people say markets are efficient and every,
the stock price is incorporate all information.
Well,
I don't think they are efficient.
And this is an example of readily,
for example,
you know,
in a sense a efficient markets would require that everybody,
every analyst rushes out and completes Eric [inaudible] study.
Uh,
but they don't,
I dunno,
it's just,
there isn't enough,
uh,
initiative in the,
in the world.
Not many people do it.
So red leaf was able to figure out who was going to get hit for the backdating
scandal before,
uh,
before other people did.
And then that was an advantage.
I'll give another example of red leafs success.
General Motors,
uh,
as you know,
as an auto producer in the United States and it hasn't been doing well,
uh,
as you may have heard,
as,
as the general auto industry in this country,
it's,
it's suffering under competition from abroad.
Uh,
and so Andrew Red Leaf bought General Motors bonds,
which are selling at a discount because people worry that General Motors won't
be able to pay on them.
And then he asked to speak to the General Motors,
that management,
and he went there and he made a plea that General Motors should cut its
dividend.
It pays to stockholders,
uh,
which is a reasonable thing to do if they're,
if they're failing,
they should cut their dividend.
But companies are reluctant to do that because it looks bad.
And so they hold off for a long time,
not cutting,
but red leaf went in and said,
you should really do it.
And he convinced him apparently,
and they cut their dividend.
Well after that the bond price went up because people saw that as a sign that
the company was tightening its belt and you know,
doing things right to have money to pay off the bond holders.
So it was self interested.
I suppose he,
maybe you can ask him about this,
but it was also what we call shareholder activism or investor activism that he
was getting involved in changing the way corporations do business.
So,
uh,
those are just a couple of examples of,
of red leaf and what he does.
Uh,
so I admire him.
I think he has a,
it's his curiosity and diligence that he finds a investment opportunities.
And he's another example that markets are really not efficient or they're
efficient enough that you have to work hard to find opportunities,
but,
but not,
uh,
not perfectly.
Okay.
So today I want to talk about banking.
And,
uh,
this,
this ties in somewhat to my previous lecture,
which was unreal estate because banks are major real estate lenders and
investors in real estate securities.
And we're going through a subprime crisis right now,
which is a banking crisis as well.
Uh,
and so I will talk a little bit about,
um,
about what we,
what we discussed last time.
Uh,
but anyway,
I wanted to start out with the most fundamental thing is,
um,
what are banks?
Okay.
What does a bank,
uh,
and,
so,
uh,
historically money lenders of one sort or another go back,
to who knows how far back thousands of years.
So you might say banks existed in ancient times,
but,
um,
the history of banking often goes back only a matter of hundreds of years.
Uh,
and one of the stories that,
uh,
is often told is the goldsmith bankers.
The story that goes back,
I don't know how many hundred years,
goldsmiths or people who,
uh,
work in gold,
they make jewelry and gold,
silver or gold where,
and the,
uh,
whatever coffee urns,
and,
uh,
they would store a goal and they would have a safe or some sort of safekeeping.
And so a lot of people would,
um,
ask them since they had a safekeeping for gold,
could you put my goal in your safe?
Uh,
and the Goldsmith,
uh,
would accept that as part of an extension of the business as a goldsmith.
Uh,
and,
um,
especially if the,
if the goal was in the form of coins and people didn't care,
uh,
whether they got the same coins back,
the Gold Smith then discovered all this gold sitting in my safe,
uh,
is just sitting there.
Why don't I learned some of it out?
Okay.
And I can earn interest on the loan and make money.
Uh,
and meanwhile,
when people,
well,
when people come back to ask for their gold,
as long as they're willing to take other gold,
that's apparently what they,
they don't care whether it's the same coins.
I'll have enough still in my safe so that I can pay them off.
Okay.
And so it,
it kind of just happened,
uh,
it was,
you know what,
it would happen to anyone who was a goldsmith because it's just the logical
extension of the business.
Some customers want to use your safe because safes are hard and expensive to
get,
uh,
and,
and some,
and then you've got all this gold,
so you might as well end it out.
So it started out that way as a,
what we call fractional reserves.
And that is
the goldsmith only had a fraction of the gold that was in,
uh,
owed by,
by the Goldsmith.
So,
uh,
the goldsmith might also write notes,
promising so much gold and not promising a,
the return of any particular item of gold.
And so the golden was signed,
his name on it saying,
I promise to give so many ounces of gold.
And in some cases they were there notes.
That means that the goldsmith would pay it to the bearer and other cases they
would have the name of the person on them,
but bearer notes became very important.
So the Goldsmith in your town writes out a note saying,
I will pay to the bearer of this note.
So much gold.
Uh,
and then the bearer,
it'd be anyone,
uh,
that you still have to hide the note for from theft,
but at least you don't have to hide a whole bunch of gold from theft.
And so that's how paper money got started as bearer notes because if you had
gold with the Goldsmith,
you could,
uh,
spend the note,
at least within the town that you live in are where the goldsmith was known and
had a reputation.
Uh,
and so that's the whole idea of how banking got started.
Um,
so,
uh,
on how paper money he got started in,
at least in the West,
uh,
there's a different history in China.
Uh,
so,
okay.
So there are different kinds of banks.
Uh,
today I'm going to jump to modern times.
And the most important time is called
commercial bank.
Okay.
And
a commercial bank,
like a Goldsmith banker accepts deposits.
It's critical.
That means you can put money in the bank,
uh,
and it makes loans.
Okay.
Very simple.
Uh,
and so the,
it pays interest on the deposit and it collects interest on the loans and it
charges a higher interest on the loan,
then they pay on the deposit and the differences there,
profit.
And that's how they make money.
Uh,
so that's,
uh,
and uh,
in addition to commercial banks,
um,
we,
uh,
well I'm not going to talk about investment banks here in this.
That's another lecture.
Investment banks are very different in that a pure investment bank does not
accept deposits.
Uh,
and it doesn't make loans.
It's an underwriter for securities.
So,
uh,
I'm not talking about investment banks in this.
I'm talking about commercial banks,
which accept deposits from depositors and traditionally commercial banks,
uh,
did not deal with the general public.
Uh,
they were for wealthy people and business people.
And the traditional commercial bank would accept deposits from businesses and
make loans to businesses.
Uh,
and that's the,
uh,
but the other,
kinds of depositary institution that have developed are called thrifts.
Uh,
and it really started from a movement,
um,
uh,
in the United Kingdom.
That's the way I do the history.
It may have some other version if you look further.
But in the United Kingdom,
there was a movement,
uh,
in the early 19th century to fat set up,
saving banks,
which were for,
uh,
this was an effort to democratize finances.
I would put it for ordinary people to have the opportunity to make small
deposits.
It used to be that people would hide money in their house and it would
frequently get stolen and it didn't earn any interest.
And so saving there was a savings bank movement,
which spread from the u s from the UK to the US in the 19th century.
Uh,
and it was a philanthropic movement.
in other words,
wealthy people in an effort to alleviate tenurey would create a savings bank.
So,
for example,
here in new haven,
we had one created called the new haven saving bank,
uh,
which lasted for over a hundred years and it was taken over.
It's now called alliance bank.
It's no longer a saving back.
Uh,
but,
uh,
a lot of these savings banks tend to be very old institutions that,
um,
that go back to the 19th century.
And,
uh,
another example is the saving and loan
association.
Uh,
this is also,
you know,
I keep thinking how British we are.
This is New England and this is the United States,
a former British colony.
A lot of things that we do here have their origins in Britain.
This also came from a UK movement called the Building Society Movement,
uh,
which spread to the u s so [inaudible] savings and loans are the same as
building societies.
Uh,
but the idea is,
uh,
the original idea and the,
the,
and also the general idea today is that these are banks set up for a small
savers in order that they can buy a house so that that savings and loans
traditionally have made most of their loans in the form of home mortgages.
So the idea,
it was a lot of people can't afford to have a house.
It's all get together and pool our money and then we'll in a building society or
saving and Loan Association and then we'll loan will loan out to some of us to
buy the house,
uh,
and it will help,
rather than all trying to do it individually.
Uh,
and then there's also something called credit unions.
Credit unions are they,
I think they came out of kind of the cooperative movement.
There's a lot of social movements that have some idealism behind them.
I think maybe the same movement that created the Yale Cooperative Society in the
late 18th century,
the 19th century,
uh,
also spurred credit union.
A credit union is a kind of club of people who belong to some organization or
live in one town or are somehow connected,
uh,
which is the boast to,
accept deposits and make loans to the members,
uh,
for things including home mortgages,
but going broader than that into automobile loans.
But it wouldn't have been automobile loans when these are created,
I dunno,
something loans,
um,
et cetera.
So it's like a saving and loan association,
except that credit unions are created by some entity,
some club or group,
and they're not open to the whole public savings and loan associations by the
way,
no longer exclusively limit themselves to mortgage lending,
either that they do home improvement lending and uh,
and uh,
auto loans and the like as well.
Okay.
So I wanted to give you some idea of the size of these.
So I have data on the total assets of these classes of bank in the United
States,
uh,
as of,
2007 third corner.
That's my date.
Uh,
so,
uh,
commercial banks had put it down here.
Uh,
10,000,
872 billion in assets,
or that's 10,
10 point $8 trillion of assets at the end of 2007,
about 20% of that is actually foreign.
Uh,
we've had a lot of big foreign commercial banks come in to the u s uh,
it's not as big as in some other countries.
If you go down to Mexico,
their main commercial banks are almost entirely foreign today.
But in the U S it's stands at,
uh,
well,
I know the domestic figure of commercial banks,
the assets of domestic commercial banks is seven,
nine,
eight,
7 billion.
So it's about $8 trillion.
Uh,
that's,
that's domestic banks.
So,
uh,
those are the big ones.
Uh,
but if you look at,
um,
uh,
now I have these two lump together,
I don't have them separately.
Um,
in 2007,
three,
they were one,
eight,
six,
8 billion.
That's almost $2 trillion.
So they're much smaller,
uh,
savings,
banks and savings and loans.
Then the commercial banks,
and,
uh,
the credit unions are even smaller,
748 $1 billion.
So it's less than 1 trillion in credit unions.
So when we speak of banks,
it is overwhelmingly commercial banks that matter.
Uh,
but,
um,
there's another way to rate these rank.
These is by numbers,
a number of banks,
and that gives you a very different look.
If you look at number of organizations that do this business,
it comes completely reversed.
And it's credit unions that are the most important.
Uh,
and where do I have that here?
Oh,
yeah.
Um,
I don't have the latest data.
This is from 1998,
but there were 11,000 credit unions.
That's the number of credit unions in the United States in 1998.
Uh,
and there were only 9,000 commercial banks.
That's the number of banks.
Um,
and of the savings institutions,
there was only 1,500.
It's probably going down further because a lot of these old savings banks are
being,
are being converted into commercial banks.
Uh,
so,
uh,
you may have a false impression of the importance of credit union.
You hear about credit unions a lot,
uh,
because they're in your neighborhood and they're advertising for small
depositors.
So they're in your face.
But the commercial banks are actually much more important.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I wanted to clarify just what it is that banks do and they're in a first thing
to understand is that I start out by telling you the story of the Goldsmith
banker.
And I like to tell that story because it sounds obvious,
right,
that if you were a goldsmith,
uh,
hundreds of years ago,
you would have probably become a banker.
It would just be the natural thing to do,
right?
So banks are natural and fractional reserve banking is a natural thing to do.
Hence,
it exists in every country of the world.
It's everywhere.
Uh,
and so it's not,
uh,
it's not something we can live without.
It must be fundamental reasons for it.
And I wanted to go over some of the fundamental reasons
why we have,
why we have banks.
Uh,
and I've got three main reasons there.
adverse selection,
moral hazard and liquidity.
Uh,
so,
uh,
in other words,
the bank offers solutions to all three problems.
Adverse selection.
I'll define this in a minute.
Moral hazard in lending
and liquidity.
Okay.
So,
uh,
and this goes beyond the simple Goldsmith banker story that I was a motivating
initially.
So what am I,
what do I mean by adverse selection?
The adverse selection problem when you,
when it comes to Bowers,
people who are trying to borrow money,
uh,
is that if you become a lender a or let's say if you,
that's how about becoming a lender.
Suppose you are interested in investing in debt of companies.
Uh,
then you as a investor sub are,
are,
are subject to the problem that you might end up with.
The worst stuff.
If you don't watch out,
suppose you,
you know,
you,
you are a naive investor and you say,
okay,
I'm going to invest in companies,
uh,
paper,
which is a,
their promises to pay their IOUs.
But the problem is I,
being a naive investor could get stuck with the bad stuff.
The people who are in the know know who's trustworthy,
uh,
as a,
as a bower and who has a good prospect of paying it back.
But if I go in there ignorantly,
uh,
I'm going to get stuck with the worst stuff that's adverse selection that you
worry that uh,
someone is going to a,
is not going to get,
you can't judge it well yourself.
And so the fat,
the fat,
your ability or inability to judge the ability of a company to pay is,
is very,
uh,
makes it very difficult for you to invest.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the,
this leads us to,
uh,
what's called relationship thanking.
Virtually all banking relationship banking.
But the core of banking is relationship banking.
Banks are institutions that exist within the community and they are live among
the business people in the community and have an ongoing relationship with him.
In fact,
that is essential to banking and
uh,
and,
and it's,
it's kind of part of the,
the almost call it the definition of a bank.
A bankers play golf a lot.
That's because a business people like to play golf and you have to keep your
finger on the pulse of the community.
Playing golf with the local businessmen is a very thing to do if you're a
banker,
right?
Because you'll hear the gossip.
It'll all be off the cuff.
Things that no one would want to tell you because they wouldn't want to be on
record of having called you up and told you that such and such a company is in
trouble,
that they're doing something that I think is looks a little funny to me.
You can't call up the banker and say that,
but if you're playing golf,
it comes out perfectly naturally.
Right.
Are you,
you joined the Yale Club in New York like that and you sit around and talk with
people.
Uh,
I remember reading a,
uh,
I like to browse and Manuel books.
I was reading a 19th century book about how to be a banker and the book dress
that you've just got to be available.
You know,
you're sitting there behind your glass window and someone comes in and wants to
chat.
You should be available.
Uh,
[inaudible] what banking is,
you're kind of in this but you in a different thing.
You're not a regular businessmen and running a business,
you're a lender to the businesses.
But as a result,
people invest in banks,
stock the stock of banks because they understand that these people have a
longterm relationship with business and they are immune from the adverse
selection.
You can't stick your bad paper to the,
to the banker who knows everybody in the town,
you know,
he'll figure it out.
And that's the,
um,
and so that's the problem that's solved by bankers.
The other thing is moral hazard,
uh,
and this is that companies,
once they borrow money from anybody,
a bank or anyone else,
they have an obligation which is fixed in dollar terms,
right?
Uh,
they have an incentive to take big risks because,
um,
uh,
think of it this way.
Suppose here a company that has just borrowed $1 million,
okay?
And now,
hey,
it's looking a little bit for carious here that,
uh,
our business might go under.
So you have an incentive to say,
cause you're the equity holder,
you have an incentive to say,
hey,
why don't I just take some big gamble here and not tell anybody.
I'll just take the remaining money and we'll put it in some lottery bet.
Uh,
and you know,
one in three chance I'll have $3 million and if it fails,
hey those guys will lose out because you know,
I'm,
I'm going to lose anyway.
I might as well,
if I don't do anything,
I'm going to lose anyway.
I'm just going to be paying back my debts and go bankrupt.
So I'll take a big gamble and then at least I have a one in three chance of
making money.
You see that isn't that compelling?
How are coming?
It doesn't you want to do.
Um,
and so,
uh,
businesses of course can't actually invest in the lottery that would be contrary
to the terms of their loan,
but they can do similar things.
They can do big gamble type business ventures.
Okay.
Uh,
and so again,
that is a problem that lenders have,
that the,
uh,
the company that's borrowing the money has this unfortunate incentive at least
at certain times to take excessive risks.
Because the debtors we'll end up varying the losses and not the debt.
The creditors who lent the money will end up,
uh,
we'll end up bearing the losses.
So this is another reason why we want real relationship banking.
It's exactly what you find out about when you're playing golf with the other
bankers.
Uh,
and so you're on the phone with this guy all the time and,
uh,
you sniff something out,
you can,
uh,
maybe stop it and so you're watching over the company.
Um,
okay.
And,
and the third thing is,
um,
is liquidity.
And that is,
uh,
maybe this is,
goes back to the,
I didn't mention it,
but it would apply to the old Goldsmith banker story as well.
Liquidity is that banks land long,
uh,
and borrow short.
But short term,
I mean,
uh,
most of the people who want to borrow money from the banks,
let's talk about businesses were accepting business loans.
They don't want to pay the extra money tomorrow.
If you're borrowing money for a business,
you might want to open a store and you want to stock your merchandise.
Uh,
and you know,
your business won't prosper for a couple of years,
uh,
or you might be building a factory and you can't pay the money back right away.
You need,
you need the loan for years.
But,
uh,
investors don't want to tie up their money for years.
So what banks offer a is liquidity and the ability to borrow short even though
the loans that are made are long term.
And how do banks do it?
They do it with fractional reserves.
They trust to the fact that,
uh,
that the bank,
that the depositors won't all come on the same day,
just like a Goldsmith banker.
He leaves only enough gold in the safe to cover the kind of withdrawals that are
normally accepted.
And so,
uh,
in that case,
the,
the bank can pay interest to depositors and even though the,
the deposits are short term and the deposit or can get the money at any time,
the deposit is earning interest of a level that can only be made using a on long
term loans.
People can't pay,
can't pay,
they can't pay a high interest if they don't have it as a long term loan.
Now incidentally,
often banks loans to corporations are short term technically.
So the corporation,
it's the bank is both lending short and borrowing short.
Uh,
but in fact they are in practice long term because you have a relationship with
your banker.
Okay.
And you play golf with your banker and your banker understands that you have a
business.
It is your friend.
Let's hope your banker understands that your business,
uh,
can't pay the money back.
And uh,
that the bank has a reputation in the community of helping business people.
Uh,
and so they won't ask for the money even though it's short term loan that they
made to the bank won't ask for it back right away.
Uh,
unless you start misbehaving.
And so I see it becomes an arm twisting thing because of this risk of moral
hazard.
The bank has a threat to take the money back and they are going to find out
quickly if you are as a company are behaving wrong.
And so,
uh,
so,
so it works out under normal circumstances very well.
So it goes beyond all of these.
The companies get advice from the banker as well.
The banker knows everybody in the community and on your playing golf with the
banker,
it may go beyond just
collecting information.
The banker might have positive suggestions,
uh,
you know,
you should really do business with so and so,
uh,
who has a natural matchup with you.
Uh,
and so bankers require a lot of,
uh,
prestige and status in their communities.
Uh,
and so this is happening all over,
all over the world.
Uh,
now banking as a,
uh,
it's important to know that banking is bigger,
in developing countries
and an LDL say LDCs less developed countries than in developed countries.
Uh,
and that is,
it tends to be bigger and that is because less developed countries have less
developed securities regulation and laws and traditions.
So that,
uh,
there it often has to be that the only way you can raise money for a business is
through a bank.
In the more advanced countries,
there is more trust in the securities markets.
And so we don't need this relationship banking as much.
Um,
but if it's still,
it still becomes very important,
uh,
to,
um,
uh,
a lot of things.
Now,
uh,
I wanted to mention in this context because I'm emphasizing how,
banks solve,
help solve the adverse selection and moral hazard problem.
I wanted to mention briefly here also the rating agencies which,
uh,
have some fulfill some of these functions and I don't have a,
a separate lecture on these.
Uh,
the first rating agency,
uh,
in the world,
was created by Mr. John Moody
in the u s in 1909.
Uh,
and he was dealing also with the moral hazard and adverse selection problem,
but he had a neat idea.
Um,
and that was a,
to give letter grades to securities that represented credit worthiness.
So the highest grade was a,
uh,
and that was the best grade you could get.
There's no eight pluses.
It sounds a little bit like college,
but not quite.
And then if you weren't quite a,
you were Aa a,
and if you weren't quite a,
you were a,
uh,
and then you can become Ba,
all the way down,
I guess to see or beyond that,
then you're failing.
It's just almost like college.
Great.
Uh,
and the idea was that the,
so he set up Moody's Rating Agency and,
and the job of Moody's was to give letter grades to securities.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it was a little bit like a bank,
but it was different because he didn't actually make the loans.
Um,
there was another Henry Poor,
uh,
set up pores in 1916 on a similar model,
and they later merged with standard statistics to become a standard and Poor's s
and p.
And those are the two biggest rating agencies in the U s today.
And they're extremely powerful organizations,
um,
because they,
uh,
and standard and Poor's also does letter grades a slightly different system,
but almost the same.
And then there's Fitch is the third,
which is smaller than these two.
Um,
so this is an interesting question.
Do they solve the moral hazard,
an adverse selection problem as well as banks do?
Uh,
well there's similar to banks and they have a relationship with the investment
community and they,
uh,
they try to stay on top of everything that's happening.
Uh,
and,
uh,
they become forces of nature in the u s economy in the sense that,
people accept these letter grades with a great authority,
uh,
and,
recently,
however,
there is a bit of a scandal regarding these rating agencies because,
uh,
they gave AAA ratings to some subprime securities and other words,
securities that were themselves backed by subprime loans.
And so this is the subprime scandal showing up.
Uh,
and the,
the question is,
uh,
how can these raging rating agencies,
manage the current distrust that's developed because they,
uh,
one important thing,
John Moody was a very crusty,
um,
strong willed man,
uh,
who wrote a couple of books.
And in these books he talked about his moral commitment to honest rating of,
of securities.
Uh,
and people trusted him and they trusted his organization.
Well,
they still do massively,
although a little bit less than they used to.
Uh,
and uh,
but something Moody's died in the 19th,
John Moody died in the 1950s,
but after he died,
uh,
Moody's and Standard and poor did something that moody would not have approved
of is they started accepting fees from the people they rate.
Uh,
and so some people think that if you,
you shouldn't do that.
If you're like a professor shouldn't be paid by the students at this,
not directly.
Maybe you're paying me indirectly,
but you know,
I shouldn't be collecting money from you.
And then awarding grades,
that wouldn't be right.
But that's what he started to happen to.
Some people think that the rating agencies have allowed a kind of moral hazard,
uh,
to creep into their organization.
So they have been working on improving their methods and they're trying to,
uh,
create divisions within their organizations that prevent the moral hazard from
happening.
I think that going forward,
uh,
both the rating agencies and the banks will be,
very important,
uh,
in our society.
And so,
uh,
the history of financial innovation is always that the,
organizations adapt to crises and the subprime crisis is harming both the
banking sector and the rating agencies at the present time because it's assist
situation of stress that that stresses their,
uh,
their organizations.
And,
uh,
but I think that it will be a time of a correction.
Um,
I mentioned fractional reserves,
uh,
and I,
um,
uh,
the fact that banks whole only a part of their,
liabilities as reserves,
like the Goldsmith banker only holding part of the gold,
uh,
is a problem.
The question is how much reserves should a hold.
Uh,
and bank failures occur when there's not enough gold in the vault.
And then people start asking for the goal and the Goldsmith banker doesn't have
it to give out.
The Basel Accord was in,
uh,
1988,
and you can read about this in detail in,
um,
for Bozi had,
uh,
was an international convention that,
gave what they call risk based capital requirements,
uh,
and recommended risk based capital requirements,
to bank regulators around the world.
What we have is we have a problem that,
that there can be a systemic problem to fractional reserve banking if there's
ever a run on the banking system.
If,
if banks get in trouble and they can't pay out,
if one bank gets in trouble and can't pay out on it's the deposits,
then that can bring the whole system down because it can cause a panic among
investors,
among depositors in banks,
and create a run on the bank.
And this has happened so many times in history that governments around the world
now regulate banks and tell them that they have to hold a minimum amount of
reserves,
uh,
and have a minimum amount of capital and capital is the money that they have to
pay out,
should there be a,
um,
it's assets that they can quickly liquefy and payout if should there be a run on
the bank.
So Basel 1988 was an effort to make sophisticated risk management requirements
for banks,
uh,
that,
that relied on more modern as of 1988,
uh,
financial theory.
So,
um,
and the,
the,
the u s adopted the Basel,
uh,
requirements in 1989 and they're still enforced today.
So the,
um,
the,
the agreement,
but incidentally this was a international convention.
No country had the follow these risks,
but generally countries have followed them because they want to be part of the
international community and you want to use the standards that were recommended.
So it's a little bit like the nic,
the National Association of Insurance Commissioners recommends laws to the local
insurance regulators in the 50 United States.
This is a supernatural national version of this.
This is in Swiss Basel as a city in Switzerland where the bank for international
settlements is,
it's an international effort to recommend regulations for countries all over the
world.
Uh,
and so in the Basel one,
there were tier one capital requirements.
Uh,
and,
uh,
when I say they define tier one capital,
as,
uh,
capital in a certain form,
it stockholders' equity plus preferred stock.
And then there's tier two capital.
Uh,
and then they have a formula.
This is defined in for those,
they have a formula that defines how much tier one and tier two capital event
has to hold.
Uh,
and the,
the amount depends on,
uh,
the risk class of their investments.
So they defined for credit risk categories,
uh,
and,
they,
uh,
they defined a formula involving the amount of assets in each of the categories.
Uh,
and then there's a formula that dictates how much tier one capital and how much
tier two capital they have to hold.
This system has worked well for 20 years now,
uh,
but it is being superseded by another Basel Convention.
Uh,
Basel two,
which has been going on for some years now.
So this is Basel one that I just telling you about and now they've come up with
a new,
uh,
version,
Basel two.
Okay.
Uh,
and Basel two is more sophisticated.
It recognizes that,
um,
uh,
that the,
the,
um,
the risks that a bank face are very complex,
uh,
and that they are not summarize by just the classes,
of,
uh,
borrowers that were defined in Basel one.
Uh,
and it took them years.
I won't get into details on Basel two,
but it,
uh,
it,
won't get into it.
It tries to deal more sophisticatedly with,
uh,
the complexity that we have in modern finance when there's a lot of unusual
derivative securities that have,
um,
uh,
difficult to understand properties.
I think there may have to have a Basel three before too long because everything
gets more and more complex in the world.
To some extent.
The subprime crisis is a,
is a failure of Basel two,
which is not even fully born yet.
Uh,
it won't come in fully enforced in the u s until 2009.
It's already starting to have its impact in other countries.
It's already been been adopted.
Uh,
so,
uh,
the,
so I wanted to talk a little bit about problems and then I conclude I have
various,
there's been lots of banking problems in the world,
uh,
and uh,
which I,
um,
let me just mention some,
uh,
I don't know what order I should go in here.
Uh,
let me just talk a little bit.
Historically the,
uh,
s and l crisis in the United States,
1980s.
What happened?
Their savings and loan associations,
we're making bad loans,
uh,
especially in Texas,
but in lots of other states as well.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the,
um,
uh,
this was,
when Ronald Reagan was president
Reagan was a big believer in free markets.
Uh,
we had a law that actually passed,
uh,
it's called the depositary institutions deregulation and monetary control act of
1980.
It's actually before Reagan.
That's depositary institutions deregulation and Monetary Control Act.
What that did is it eliminated,
uh,
ceilings on interest rates on deposits.
It allowed banks to pay high interest rates.
It used to be that the government didn't let banks pay more than a certain
amount on their deposits.
Uh,
and that helped protect banks because then they,
they didn't,
uh,
they didn't have to compete,
to pay high interest rates and then be incentivized to make risky loans to try
to make money with those high interest rates.
Once they freed up interest rates,
interest rates on deposits started,
sorry.
And Bank started taking greater risks,
particularly savings and loans.
Now the government insurers deposits,
as you know,
through the FDA,
the Federal Deposit Insurance Corporation,
and for savings and loans,
they had an organization called the FSL IC,
which is now defunct because of this crisis,
federal savings and loan insurance corporation.
And it was insuring deposits of savings and loans.
Uh,
they should have been watching under Reagan because if you let them pay high
interest rates,
you better watch out that they don't make risky loans if you're insuring them.
But the FSL I see,
uh,
wasn't,
it was sleeping at the switch.
Uh,
and so it allowed banks in the United States,
it was primarily savings and loans.
Who did this to make bad loans,
uh,
and they were playing this moral hazard game.
The whole moral hazard crept in.
And,
uh,
because they said,
hey,
we can bow at a high rate.
Let's make some risky loans,
and if it succeeds,
we make money.
If the thing blows up,
well then the government will pay.
And so they had an,
uh,
an unfortunate incentive to make bad loans.
Uh,
this thing collapsed in the 1980s,
uh,
and it costs the u s government through the FSL.
I see about 150 billion hours.
Uh,
it also,
the collapse of this was part of the reason for a general economic collapse.
We saw a collapse in real estate prices after 1990 and a recession in 1991.
So it was the big story,
uh,
of,
um,
of the,
uh,
1980s,
I just going to mention some other stories that are important to just to
illustrate the fragility of the banking system,
the Mexican crisis,
uh,
under President Salinas.
Um,
what happened was Selena's was a Harvard educated economist came in to modernize
Mexico,
uh,
and he wanted to prioritize things.
Uh,
and so he privatized a lot of the banks.
and then the banks went on a lending spree,
uh,
and uh,
in Mexico,
uh,
and,
loans,
bank loans rose from 10% of GDP of Mexican GDP
in 1988,
uh,
two 40%
by 1994.
That's a huge increase in bank loans in Mexico.
What was happening,
it was again,
something was amiss that you did,
you had the government deregulated and not watching a lot of these people in the
Mexican banks thought,
well,
surely there'll be a bailout if something bad happens,
the government will pay for it.
So let's go,
let's run with it.
And they ran with a lot of loans that turned out bad.
As a result,
there was a huge banking crisis.
And I mentioned before that Mexico doesn't have much in the way of domestic
banks anymore.
They basically all failed and were taken over by foreign banks after the Mexican
crisis.
So that's a sign of how things can go amiss.
Um,
the Asian crisis in 1997,
1998,
uh,
it's,
97,
98.
Uh,
it actually is a complex phenomenon and not involving only banks,
but,
um,
uh,
there,
there was a,
uh,
in the,
in the mid 1990s,
Korea,
uh,
Taiwan,
Thailand,
Philippines,
other countries,
we're receiving a lot of international capital,
uh,
and from international banks.
And,
uh,
there was a sudden change of heart and people wanted to withdraw their foreign
investors wanting to withdraw their money.
Uh,
and once it,
once the rumor got started that Asia was in trouble,
these people started withdrawing our money faster and faster,
and it caused failures of,
of domestic banks in,
um,
in these countries.
Uh,
there's also the Argentine crisis,
uh,
of,
um,
2000,
2002,
uh,
once again,
it's comp,
I won't get into all the details of this,
but it ended up with a run on the Argentine banks.
And,
uh,
again,
there was a loss of confidence in the time of an eye of a economic crisis.
Uh,
and people wanted to withdraw their money from the banks.
And the government,
uh,
was panicked because it begs,
didn't have enough money to give it to them.
And so the government shut down the bank accounts,
uh,
and it led to a riding in the streets.
People were very upset that they had left their money in the bank and the
government was just saying,
you can't have it.
Um,
and it caused a huge economic crisis as well.
The unemployment rate rose to 18%.
Uh,
there was a five changes of government in Argentina in a short time.
fortunately,
Argentina has survived this crisis pretty well,
but,
uh,
it's coming back rapidly,
but there was a severe crisis.
Uh,
and so that again highlights the importance of having a good bank regulation.
Now finally,
I wanted to talk about the current situation in what's called the subprime
crisis.
Uh,
and let me talk about the u s first,
uh,
in the u s now I'm talking about just the last few years and it's something
that's continuing today.
And also it's international as well.
Um,
they're developed in the u s in recent years,
something called the shadow banking system.
And these are organizations that act like banks but are not called banks,
uh,
because they are not technically a bank.
So they escape regulation.
Typically they issue instead of deposits something called abs asset backed
securities,
uh,
well asset back securities,
particularly commercial paper,
which are short term obligations of the organization,
uh,
and they invest in,
in something longterm notably subprime loans.
Okay.
And so they're operating like banks,
but they're not regulated as banks,
so they,
Basel two doesn't apply to them and so they can do what they want.
Uh,
and unfortunately what we've seen recently is it kind of a bank run on the,
on the asset vast asset backed commercial paper banks have been creating
something called structured investment vehicles,
uh,
in recent years.
And what these are,
are,
uh,
I like companies,
but they typically don't have any employees.
Siv.
Siv is a,
uh,
is a company that was sword that invest in assets and they issue something like
asset backed commercial paper.
Uh,
but it's not a real company because it only exists as an organization sponsored
by some bank.
And so the bank has a sieve on its,
on its books,
but the sieve is not part of the bank,
so it's not subject to the bank capital requirements.
Uh,
and,
uh,
but,
but then,
you know,
you might say,
well,
who would buy the paper of a sieve?
Well,
the only people who would buy it are people who trust the bank that supports it.
And so in effect,
the bank is promising to bail out the sieve if it should get in trouble.
Uh,
and so it really is,
it really ought to be on the bank's balance sheet and ought to be regulated by
the bank regulators.
But there was a failure to do that.
Uh,
and so that is the,
um,
the problem that we are in currently.
So I wanted to talk about some very recent problems,
uh,
to illustrate that.
It's always a challenge to keep banks.
Banks are extremely useful,
uh,
entities,
but there's sort of a fundamental flaw that has to be constantly dealt with,
namely that tendency of them to fail when they're lending long and borrowing
short.
And so there's always a risk that investors will suddenly want their money bank
back.
So,
um,
I wanted to just talk about some recent examples.
Northern Iraq,
which was a building society in the United Kingdom,
had a a sudden bank run,
uh,
in September,
2007,
uh,
this is,
the northern rock.
Why was it,
what was happening in northern rock was a British building society that was
investing in subprime paper in the u s and,
uh,
it was having trouble and then word got out that it was having trouble and the
rumors started spreading in the UK.
Northern rock is going to fail.
And so people started rushing to pull all their money out of northern rock in
September of 2007.
This was the first bank run in the UK since 1866.
Uh,
this was a tremendous embarrassment to the Bank of England.
and Mervyn King,
it was a very good governor of the Bank of England,
but apparently it took him by surprise.
Uh,
they thought bank runs were a thing of the past.
The,
in fact,
the United Kingdom has been an international model for preventing of bank runs
because the Bank of England would always lend to a bank that was in trouble in
order to keep them out of the problem.
And so the US Federal Reserve system was really a copy of the Bank of England
thinking that,
well,
the Bank of England managed to prevent bank runs for all these years.
Let's create the Fed,
uh,
which we'll talk about again later.
Um,
and so they thought they had the system,
uh,
solves,
but then they had a bank run last year.
Uh,
and so you talk to these people who were standing in front of the bag.
First question you'd ask them,
aren't deposits insured in the UK?
Like they are in the u s well sure enough,
they were,
the UK had copied the u s idea.
I guess it caught,
I don't know where the original,
I think it probably,
is it UK copying the u s in this case,
but they didn't cover it well enough because they had a limit on the insurance
of 3000 pounds for full insurance.
Uh,
and then they had 90% of the deposits of to a 75,000.
Okay.
And so you got these people who are lining up in front of the bank and ask them,
isn't there deposit insurance?
And they knew perfectly well.
They said yes,
but only up to 3000 pounds.
I don't want to lose 10% of my money.
I've got 50,000 pounds in the bank.
So it was kind of a bad design for deposit insurance.
So they fixed it.
But you know,
still northern rock is in such trouble that in February of Oh eight,
let's last month the,
uh,
British government nationalized northern rock.
It's in a terrible mess.
This puts the British government in a embarrassing situation of owning a failing
a mortgage lender.
Uh,
and so they've got to now be the government collecting on all these mortgages.
it's a mess.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it shows that little details about how the deposit insurance run are important.
A lot of talk about Germany,
uh,
in,
August or actually it was a little bit earlier.
What was it?
July?
There's a bank in Germany called I K v
industry.
This is hard to write.
Three Bonk,
that's one word,
age,
uh,
that,
invested heavily in US subprime paper.
Okay.
And the,
and the,
the value of the paper collapsed and the bank became insolvent.
It was doing it through a sieve and it's a prob the Rhineland
investment vehicle.
So,
you know,
this is not just the u s this thing is heavily international problems.
This was a German bank doing exactly the same thing.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it,
it was,
uh,
became insolvent and the German government had to come to his rescue.
It turns out that 38% of this bank was owned by the German government.
And so it was kind of their problem,
right?
They weren't watching what was going on adequately.
And so there was a bailout and the bailout,
uh,
I don't have the exact number here.
It was a huge number of euros.
Uh,
and so it,
it,
it kind of was a wakeup call in Germany because they were watching with
amusement,
the subprime crisis in the United States.
And here it was causing losses to the German government.
I think it was intensive.
Billions of euros is huge.
And this wasn't the only one.
There was another German bank called Zach Oxen,
uh,
essay,
which,
uh,
failed at the same time,
I guess the two together,
I think it was 26 billion euro.
Um,
the,
to this Zach's [inaudible] lb and I,
kb was a bailout of 26 billion euro.
Uh,
and that's a huge scandal in Europe,
which is still unfolding and it drives from the u s subprime crisis.
So what was happening is these banks were not being watched carefully enough
there.
Their capital requirements were not enough for the kind of assets they were.
Um,
they were investing in a part of the problem is that the rating agencies were
rating their securities that they were investing in as triple a in many cases.
So there was a big goof up.
The rating agencies weren't,
weren't cutting the ratings as they should,
and these European banks were just kind of naively trusting,
uh,
and it just didn't get figured out.
Now it hit France to BNP Paribas is a major French bank.
Uh,
and it had,
uh,
a couple of
several funds,
power,
dynamic bnb,
uh,
power about abs for Europe or,
and BNP power of us abs Urania.
Uh,
and,
uh,
these things collapsed.
I believe the,
uh,
the three funds lost,
this is where I have done 2 trillion euros.
I'd have to check that.
That sounds high,
but it wasn't the point.
It was,
it was the same scandal that we saw in the US,
UK,
Germany,
and now France.
And it was the same source.
It was the u s housing crisis that was causing a contagion around the world,
uh,
from one country to another because the banks in the countries had invested in
risky securities that they hadn't taken proper account of the risk and they
didn't have enough reserves.
The same thing affected us banks,
uh,
as well,
in,
um,
uh,
it was bear Stearns,
whose headquarters is right next to grand central station.
If you go into New York
and they had a couple of,
um,
uh,
funds,
one was called high grade.
I like to write this down,
high grade,
uh,
structured credit
and another one was called enhanced leverage fund.
These names sound safe,
high grade enhanced,
but they both collapsed,
uh,
and became a leveraged fund.
They became almost worthless because they were investing in subprime that,
uh,
and uh,
and the,
and the value of the deck collapsed.
And uh,
so these collapsed as well.
Well,
these are just some examples.
I think we're in a very interesting time,
uh,
for banking and for the economy as a whole.
What we've seen is a testing of the system,
uh,
that,
we have regulatory requirements that banks have enough capital.
But,
uh,
this regulation is challenging because it's being stressed right now.
A lot of people get complacent during normal times and they assume that normal
times will go on forever.
They can't imagine.
They don't have the power of imagination to think of what the next crisis will
be like.
So it catches them by surprise.
But we'll figure this all out.
And banks,
as I say,
are with us,
uh,
to stay,
we just have to improve our regulation and disclosure requirements.
So that banks can,
can be prevented from taking unnecessary.
All right.
So I hope you all come to hear red leaf on Wednesday,
and I look forward to having lunch with some of you.
I don't think I can get either icon.
Both the icon and she worked,
uh,
Schwarzman are,
are coming to give a lecture in April,
but I don't think either of them will stay for lunch.
So this is our only a luncheon event.